This systematized nomenclature of
medicine SNOMED and SNOMED-CT,
a subset for clinical medicine, began in
NIH and was recently just for pathology.
Interestingly, the original objective
back in the 70s was machine coding
of a pathologist's free
text dictated note.
It was always in ontology representing
relationships among its concepts.
Today it has expanded to all of
medicine, and is maintained by
the International Health Terminology
Standards Development Organization.
SNOMED is huge and complex.
Even the SNOMED-CT subset
has 311,000 concepts.
And represents 1.3 million
relationships among them.
Concepts are a basic component of
SNOMED-CT and have clinical meaning.
They're identified by a unique
nine digit numeric concept ID and
a unique human-readable
fully specified name.
Concepts can be represented as
a hierarchy based on level of detail
as shown here where we go
at least detail from the concept of
a procedure at some site of the body
all the way to a very specific procedure
done at a very specific location.
This illustration shows other
basic components of SNOMED-CT.
Relationship links, which are expressed
using is a, and attribute relationships,
which are a finding site or
an associated morphology.
So a fracture of the tarsal bone,
is a sub type of a fracture of the foot.
The tarsal bone is part of the foot,
and has a finding site, and
an associated morphology,
the location of the fracture and
the fact that it is in fact a fracture.
The ability of SNOMED to
represent medicine and
medical concepts is illustrated here,
where we see that the patient has
a particular condition, Acute
Post-Streptococcal Glomerulonephritis,
a condition I actually
had as a teenager.
It's caused by group
A Beta-hemolytic Streptococcus,
which is an organism that
affects a body structure,
the kidneys, and it's a clinical
finding or a medical problem.
Using this hierarchy a computer
could recognize these relationships.
This is actually a simple example
showing only three of the 18
top level components in the SNOMED
hierarchy, Body Structure,
Clinical Finding, and Organism.